uh let's just bring you some breaking
news now and the north yorkshire crime
commissioner philip allet has resigned
um this is after comments he made um
about sarah everard
sarah everard of course murdered by the
former metropolitan police officer wayne
cousins the police boss made comments
that said sarah everard should never
have submitted to a fake arrest and that
women need to be streetwise about the
power that officers
have
those comments at the time causing huge
controversy he was speaking on bbc radio
york our colleagues at the yorkshire
post
revealed last night
that
uh 37 members of his own staff had
signed a letter calling for his
resignation citing sexist and
misogynistic behavior
towards his own
female members of staff that was from
the yorkshire post last night and it
seems that he has uh
succumbed to that pressure to resign and
handed in his resignation he's written
an open letter uh tendering his
resignation i'm just looking at it now
he's put over the past two weeks i have
tried to rebuild trust and confidence in
my work as york and north yorkshire's
police fire and crime commissioner i
needed to do that following comments i
made on an interview with radio york
regarding the horrific abduction rate
and murder of sarah everard i need to be
clear i apologize unreservedly for my
remarks they do not reflect my views i
misspoke and i am devastated at the
effect that this has had on victims of
crime and the groups that support them i
have tried to say this again and again
but i recognize that what i have said
has not always been heard as i intended
uh he goes on to say i had hoped i could
rebuild trust to restore confidence i
was pleased that so many victims groups
had accepted that i was genuinely sorry
and were willing to work with me to help
me in the mammoth task i had ahead and
but he goes on to say following this
morning's meeting of the police and
crime panel it seems clear to me that
the task will be exceptionally difficult
if possible at all it would take a long
time and a lot of resources of my office
and the many groups who do excellent
work supporting victims
this is time victims do not have there
are women and girls in york and north
yorkshire today suffering at the hands
of men victims and the groups who
support them need to be heard they
cannot be heard if the airwaves are
filled with discussion about my future
he goes on to say that is why he is
resigning as police fire and crime
commissioner so that is the north
yorkshire crime commissioner philip
allet
tendering his resignation in an open
letter over comments he made regarding
the murder of sarah everard and how
women
need to be more streetwise